you were at the Emmys last night you got
to present I did with Kit Harington
Herrington ladies yeah ladies love that
kid hell of a turn
also known as Jon Snow yeah yeah that
really threw him for now you're out
you're unnecessarily smug about smug
about it the only guy that knows so that
must've been fun to work with him last
night because you guys have worked
together before you have yeah we did a
tennis mockumentary called seven days
and health really but I learned like
it's a little bit dangerous to work with
people from Game of Thrones because when
you're in their sphere I'm a huge fan of
Game of Thrones that me too and I don't
want spoilers but I had a really major
one kind of blown for me because I was
working with kids because we're gonna
get on the mockumentary yeah cuz we got
like an email from the PR people at HBO
and they were like hey great news we're
gonna run the first commercial for seven
days in hell after the game of Thrones
finale and there's gonna be tons of
excitement around it because jon snow
dies just like like there's when you
like go on the wrong side or something
you get a spoiler yeah it's like a new
phenomenon but it's like slow motion of
trying to look away but you already saw
it's like seared into your brain yeah I
guess I'll watch the finale now yeah
that's a drag it was a drag it wasn't
kids fault at least it was his publicist
true he never would have spilled any
beans as we found out when he lied to
everyone for like months yeah he told
everybody I really am dead yeah and then
spoiler alert yeah oh these people
haven't seen it they don't know what I'm
glad everyone here caught up on through
yeah no they're they're they're so busy
unhappy way through season one yeah
there's so much towards all right
you